after a kind of you know unfortunate
start in which his handlers in attempt
to protect him wrote a unbelievably
stupid contract and I said you know
obviously you don't know how this thing
works Brad was very very embarrassed
that the people around him were asking
you know for all the stuff and you know
he contacted me so this is me I didn't
do this I know I know you know your work
and I just I would just like to be the
photograph and so we spent the day
together I found him to be very
interesting a guy I I think a person of
speaking of integrity a person a very
high integrity and a person with real
passion for the things for his work but
also passion for the things that he
believes in causes that that he and
Angelina are involved with and and it
was a real pleasure to get to know